every one I honestly didn't think I'd be
making another one of these but here we
are yet another ten more things you
didn't know about Dark Souls as usual
like the video if you learned something
new and disliked the video if you knew
everything
since there's 40 of these facts now
there's a playlist annotation on the
screen so you can test how many things
you knew out of 40 so let's start with a
good one something that I only found out
recently did you know that you can kill
kalameet without Goff's help all you
have to do is shoot him as he flies out
of the chasm and sweeps the area sound
easy it's not the best place to shoot
from is probably here since his location
gives you time to loose an arrow and
then switch out to your shield but [ __ ]
up once and fumble your shield and it
looks like you'll be starting over
because that does a lot of damage anyway
doing this unlocks new dialogue with
Gough where he recognizes your prowess
and expresses what an honor it is to
meet you number two once you've awoken
the undead dragon it's really difficult
to just sprint past him and avoid his
swipe but never fear since the devs put
a borderline invisible ramp here which
you can run up to get passed safely
further on there's also this little cave
with a humanity in it since everyone
just runs through the valley it's likely
these are things that you missed number
three if you drop essential items like
the Covenant of artorias or the orange
chard ring then once you reload the game
these items will be available in the
chest next time you visit number four
there are three types of resins you can
apply to your weapon in Dark Souls
rotten pine resin gold pine resin and
charcoal pine resin now what's
interesting is that these resins
correlate to the methods the Lords used
against the dragons to retake the
surface Gwyn's Lightning peeled apart
their stone scales
nito unleashed oxen corruption upon
their exposed flesh and the witch of
izalith burned down their homes the arch
trees fire lightning and toxic and
corruption number 5 when you start the
game with a night of cleric you have
your joy emote replaced with prayer you
can learn joy from Don Hall number 6 the
statues in the catacombs have family
masks on them the statue with the
mothers mask will stab you as you pass
and the statue with the father's mask
will not this would be useful
information if those stabs actually were
a threat and number 7 grave Lords are so
rare because they only appear to players
who have entered new game+ I guess this
was because Fromm didn't want to make
the game too hard for people on their
first playthrough but it really affected
the effectiveness of the Covenant number
8
wondered why you randomly get soft
humanities as you progress throughout
the world
well there's a logic to it in the form
of an invisible humanity meter which
keeps track of the enemies you've killed
once a certain value is reached a single
point of humanity will be obtained with
a total of ten available in each area
now different enemies are actually worth
a different amount of points for the
humanity meter with each subsequent
humanity requiring more kills to obtain
than the previous one number 9 I hope
you've got everything so far now this
might just be a glitch but it's a bit of
an appropriate glitch when you look up
at the Sun in Anor Londo it disappears
and then it appears regularly on and off
this ties in really well with the idea
that the lightning anor londo is an
illusion made by Gwendolyn to make it
seem like the power isn't fading clearly
he's having a hard time maintaining this
illusion and number 10 something funny
you might have missed the elevator in
Blighttown looks to be powered by this
fire dog like a hamster in a wheel and
that's it leave a like if you learned
something new and look forward to some
great content in the future